a lot of athletes you know have this
term around the a game and showing up
and doing their absolute best mentally
emotionally physically spiritually Etc
and it got me thinking about do you even
know what your A game is what has to
happen in order for you to be at your
best to play at your best is it a
routine is it a diet is it a way of
thinking is it planning what is it that
would cause you to play your A game and
so here's just a little maybe task for
you to consider take 10 minutes and ask
yourself this question in order for me
to play to be at my best here are the
things that need to happen and this make
a list of what are the things that need
to happen I know for me for example I
have routines I have routines in the
morning I've got routines in the evening
my routines give me the best opportunity
to feel my best and to do the things
that are going to give me the greatest
results that I want I've discovered that
most people never think of this and so
that's your task for today is what has
to happen in order for you to have a
great day what has to happen in the
morning in the afternoon and the evening
so think about thoughts emotions
feelings and behaviors and also think
about exercise diet and nutrition think
about meditation think about anything
that could help you have an a game day
and then go and do it need motivation
watch a top 10 with believe Nation hey
it's Evan Carmichael and I make these
videos because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best John assraff and my take on
his top 10 rules of success enjoy
rule number two create a plan hey there
great day to you I was uh just uh
talking to a friend of mine in London
while I was doing a little bit of a
workout this morning here at the house
and it dawned on me to ask you this
question because I asked him this
I said How's your health plan working
how has your income producing plan
working
how is your
managing your budget working plan how is
your spiritual awareness plan working
how is your business growth plan working
how is your career enhancement plan
working
and he shared with me that uh
he doesn't have a plan and this is a
dear friend I've known for a while
and so I asked I said without a plan
what do you expect to happen
and obviously he got the point but it
also made me aware
one of the things that I just learned
how to do
that I think
is a key factor in my successes for
whatever goal I want to achieve I create
a plan it doesn't matter how simple it
is doesn't have to be complex but I
create a plan uh here's what I'm going
to do or here's the goal right and the
vision of the outcome of that goal and
how it feels and looks and who I'm
impacting and how it's going to make me
feel
and then I just set a really simple plan
to get it started what am I going to do
on Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
Friday Saturday Sunday
put into my calendar and just do it it
doesn't have to be that difficult but in
the absence of a plan
and there's too many variables that can
get in the way it's like you know being
on a on a boat over here and you want to
go you know somewhere
you know like Hawaii which is about
eight hours that way if you don't have a
plan of where you're gonna be in a day
in two days and three hours so
ask yourself what's your plan
why not put together just a simple plan
for inner sizing to strengthen your
mindset your emotional skills your focus
your awareness put a plan together
for the actions required to achieve your
goals
and just start but be consistent right
consistency is one of the keys to
success rule number three control your
journey over the last couple of weeks as
I've been in a lot of self-reflection
mode reviewing what worked in 2019 what
didn't and why
um and as I looked at the person in the
mirror who is responsible for what
worked and what didn't
here's what I can share with you where a
few of the key distinctions and lessons
for me
number one is Details Matter
the goals that I had in 2019 where I was
really clear on the outcome and the
specifics of how I was going to achieve
it
and I built into my calendar the review
process to see whether I'm on track or
off track and to determine why
when I looked at the results that I
achieved every single goal that I
achieved was backed by the strategies
the tactics the timelines the tools and
the resources to achieve that goal and
every single goal that I didn't achieve
did not have the strategies the tactics
the timelines the tools and resources to
achieve it so what does that tell me
that I can impart and share with you
number one a goal without a clear plan
is really not enough to make it happen
and so what I've been doing for the last
two weeks for my own personal goals for
the goals with my wife for the goals
with my team for neurogym is we have
been breaking down every goal that we
are committed to achieving not that we
want to achieve that we are committed to
achieving and we are drilling down
with exactly how we're going to achieve
it
and here's what is really critical
I have a theme and that's around
slow is smooth and smooth as fast let me
explain
I tend to go fast let's go come on let's
go go come on come on come on come on
and for some things that works and for
other things it just doesn't work and so
I am going to be working on
focusing on slowing down
to get all the plans systems processes
in place
so that we can actually pick up speed
instead of let's go and figure it out
along the way
so for you
why not maybe adopt you know my theme
for at least a month slow down to pick
up speed and take every one of your
goals for this quarter
and slowed down enough to ask yourself
how am I going to achieve that goal
whether it's a health goal relationship
goal career goal business goal Financial
goal
how are you going to do it and come up
with your plan and it doesn't matter if
your plan is you know simple or complex
but come up with your plan and then take
that plan and put it into your calendar
and then work your plan every day every
week every month every quarter and then
adjust on a regular basis many of you
know that I take about 15 to 20 minutes
every morning to look at my plan for the
day my appointments for the day the
outcomes for the day I take about 20 to
30 minutes every Sunday night to review
my week and to plan the following week I
take about two to three hours every
month to review the month and then I
take a day every quarter to review the
quarter why
well imagine that we were on a you know
on a boat on the water over there we
were going from here in San Diego let's
say we were going to the South Pacific
Islands we'd pick our destination and
then we would check are we on track or
are we off track on a regular basis and
maybe there's a GPS system on the boat
that tells us you know you're you're
heading in the right direction or you're
not heading the right direction making
some auto corrections but there's also
the pi the captain right making
adjustments based on the the wind the
temperature of the water the waves Etc
so why not become the captain of your
own ship with your destination the
points you're going to achieve along the
way and a bunch of points in between the
check and balance checking balance check
and balance check and balance the more
frequently you check and balance are you
on track or off track doing the right
things or not
the more you can predict whether you're
going to achieve your goals and dreams
well number four learn to adapt first
and foremost you know I like to deal
with reality
of what is going on and what is the
truth first and foremost now let me ask
you a question
would you agree that
times of uncertainty times maybe a fear
for some people times of stress for some
people is also a time for us to learn
how to adapt
isn't adaptation one of the greatest
skills okay that we as humans can learn
and many years ago when I was in the
Galapagos Islands I bought a hat and if
you have ever been to the Galapagos
you'll know that it's like going back
five million years and there's a saying
there and I got this hat says adapt or
die why because the survival of the
fittest okay the whole idea of survival
of the fittest is based on Darwin's work
and we actually retraced his trail with
uh with the Beagle when he was writing
about the survival of the fittest and
learning about adaptation is the animals
that learn to adapt were the ones that
survived the ones that got to survive
obviously multiplied so here is my
question for you okay we are sometimes
the most advanced species on Earth uh
most intelligent I'm going to say
sometimes right what are you doing to
adapt right now
what are you doing to adapt right now
what are you doing to adapt mentally
what are you doing to adapt emotionally
what are you doing to adapt physically
what are you doing to adapt spiritually
what are you doing to adapt financially
right those are the five places of
adaptation right so spiritually
emotionally mentally physically
financially so what are you doing okay
to adapt
right what are you doing to adapt when
there are things happening in our
environment
whose responsibility is it to adapt
all right so let me share something with
you if it's true that adaptation is a
skill
right if it's true that you know as a
human species we have the ability to
adapt let me give you a couple of things
that may help okay and I like that
praying yeah
um share with me you know what you're
doing diverge I guess you didn't like my
comments because you're still here right
so share with me how do you manage let's
start with number one how do you manage
your mindset
to go from being reactive to being
responsive is that something that every
one of us can do when we're reacting
it's usually without any thought
right it's usually without any thought
when we're responding it's usually
because of thought
right and I don't mean just thoughts I
mean thinking so the way I like to do it
is say here's what's happening whether
it's you know interest rates uh the
market crashing covet monkey pox uh the
Texas shooting which please you know
let's say some prayers to all of the
families all of the families
um you know that are going through this
nightmare right now but what can we do
what you and I can do to respond instead
of react
right so naturally depending on the
situation we may react in anger
um and that's that's a part of our fight
flight response right we're going to act
out of anger and blame and shame and
guilt
um that's right but we may act in a
state of fear right fear is a protective
State since the number one priority of
our brain is to avoid any uh pain or
discomfort but also to make sure that
anything that is happening around us
right
um is manage for survival and safety
survival and safety also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five have discipline
every one of us is 100
self-disciplined already to our current
thought patterns emotional patterns and
behavioral patterns which obviously are
responsible for our results so
my question for you today is this
do you have the right disciplines
do you have the right disciplines to set
goals create plans and Achieve them do
you have the right disciplines to prime
your brain with your vision your goals
and your plans for the day every day do
you have the right discipline to review
your day at the end of the day to see
what did you do well what could be
tweaked so that tomorrow is even better
do you take time on Sunday nights for
maybe 30 or 40 minutes to plan your week
so that you're not reacting to stuff but
you're planned you're organized you're
in action that's deliberate versus
reactive that's another discipline
do you take time every month to review
your month do you take time every
quarter to review your quarter do you
take time at the end of each year to
review the whole year and then to plan
your vision for the next year your goals
for the next year now
these little disciplines are what I call
Keystone disciplines or Keystone
behaviors and habits that set you up for
success and so
I like to consistently ask myself do I
have the right Keystone habits the the
big things you know that swing the
little hinges That Swing the big doors
so a couple things I can tell you that
really work for me
is taking the time to think to plan to
review my results and in a state of no
blaming myself no shaming myself no
feeling guilty no justifying no wishing
I wish it was different or better or
this or that just in a pure state of
awareness I tweak and adjust and tweak
and adjust and tweak and adjust and
tweak and adjust
and here's what happens what you'll
discover is you're going to be on course
A lot of the time you're going to be off
course some of the time but when you
take the time to recognize if your
thoughts are aligned with your vision
and your goals are your emotions your
your things that cause you to take
action and not align with your vision
and goals are the behaviors that you're
taking aligned with achieving those
goals now
when you're in a constant state of
review tweak adjust behave review tweak
adjust behave that is a self-disciplined
action and habit
that will lead you to achieve every one
of your health wealth relationships
career business charitable every goal
you have
the how to achieve the goal is the
easiest part getting yourself to take
the inspired action because you have a
big reason why you must
is really what you need to work on
because we all are going to have
challenges we're going to have failures
we're going to have days we feel like on
top of the world and other days we feel
like oh man I just don't even feel like
getting out of bed that's okay that's
normal that's called being human
but if you have the self-discipline to
get up and do a little bit to get up and
adjust and tweak then you win the game
more than you lose the game think about
Athletics for just a moment
to make it into the Hall of Fame for
exactly for example in baseball you will
not hit
3 out of ten balls you will not hit him
you will not get on base that means
you're failing so to speak seven out of
ten times but to make it to the hall of
fame the best of the best all you need
to do is hit get on base three times so
a lot of people have a misunderstanding
of success and that is that you succeed
every single minute every single hour
every single day and that's not just not
true right the most successful people in
the world are consistently taking action
making sure that it's the right action
if it's not they adjust so have the
self-discipline to not blame shame
justify or make yourself feel guilty
have the self-discipline to create the
plans take inspired action manage your
thoughts get into the right State the
physiology the feelings that you need in
order to achieve your goals dreams take
inspired action daily and don't focus on
Perfection focus on a little bit of
progress every single day rule number
six develop good habits every one of us
has got commitments uh whether it's
commitments to our family our friends
our children our boss our employees our
parents our siblings we all have so many
commitments in every area of Our Lives
health wealth relationships career
business fun experiences charity and how
are we supposed to
manage all of it
and the answer is very carefully
one of the only ways that I have learned
how to manage the complexities of life
is to compartmentalize the different
areas of life and to set up a process of
prioritization based on the highest
values in the doing the things that have
to get done before any of the other
things now the reason I bring this up is
Harry who I just had lunch with as I
mentioned he was sharing with me that
one of the things that helped him last
year was that I gave him this framework
to be able to manage some of the
complexities that were happening in his
very very successful and busy life and
the framework I gave him was to take
each area of his life and either create
you know a sheet of paper that he can
write on a white board that he could
write on or even on your computer and
ask yourself in the area of your whether
it's spiritual health
what is one thing that you can do if
that's important to you
every day or every week to make sure
that you can get that done
in the area of your emotional health and
well-being what's one thing that you
want to get done in the area of your
mindset what's one thing you can get
done in the area of your physical body
what's one thing that you can get done
either every day or every week or every
month depending on what it is that you
want to achieve and then you do the
exact same thing for your business
there aren't 500 different things that
you and I have to do when we focus on
the one thing in each area of our life
and we get that one thing done
then we're making progress we're moving
the needle down the field now in some
areas of your life of course there's
going to be two or three things but when
you get it out of your head and on to
something that you can look at you get
rid of the neural overwhelm and the
emotional anxiety that comes by having
so many things that you're trying to
think through in your brain so most
people I've found
they don't take any time to plan
their health wealth relationships career
business and they have no order to what
they need to do what they must do and by
when
and so when you structure your your
behaviors from highest importance to
lowest you'll see that some of the
lowest imp things that need to get done
aren't the most impactful they're not
the ones that move the needle now it
just takes a little bit of time to sit
to sit to stop what you're doing
sit
think a little bit create some list for
health wealth relationship career
business fun and experiences and charity
there's your seven categories and then
itemize the stuff that you want to get
done
give yourself the gift of discipline
give yourself the gift of structure give
yourself the gift of thinking before you
act and then tweak and adjust on a daily
or weekly basis and I promise you you
will become so much more effective
you'll reduce your stress you'll reduce
your anxiety you'll increase your
productivity and chances are you're
gonna increase being happier and achieve
more of your goals rule number seven
take care of your well-being I was just
thinking about
the amount of stress that each one of us
has on a day-to-day week-by-week basis
and I know that we're all focusing on
achieving our goals health goals wealth
goals relationship career business fund
experiences and one of our health goals
should also be you know well-being
and so my question for you is do you
have a well-being plan
now
I have a lot of stress in my life
mostly business related just the amount
of work that I want to get done the
goals I want to achieve and the company
that I want to build and so I work a lot
of hours even when I'm on vacation like
I am right now I'm thinking about
business I'm thinking about a lot of
different things and what I can share
with you for me that works for me is I
also have a Wellness Plan
that includes you know proper eating
proper sleep proper nutrients in the
form of vitamins minerals Etc I also
have a exercise regiment a meditation
regiment a vacation plan as well now all
this may sound like a lot of planning
and the truth is when you take the time
to think about how do you get yourself
in the best mental emotional spiritual
and physical health so that you can
achieve all of the goals that you have
with all the stress of learning new
things of making mistakes of things not
working out
and the only way to do that is you have
to step back sometimes and allow
yourself to rejuvenate first
so that you can actually think about the
goals you have but also the plans to
achieve them
so I like to get to my home here in
Telluride Colorado and ski several times
during the you know winter season and
several times in the summer season I
like to travel a lot and what I find for
me is that it rejuvenates me at every
level of the game now you may be
thinking well I can't afford to take the
time off and the truth is you can't
afford not to one of my dear friends Dr
Barnett Meltzer once said if you don't
make time for your health
your illness will make time for you
and so in this world of massive amounts
of social media people pulling for our
attention online and offline in our
families and our own you know gyrations
of what goes on into our heads
you have to figure out what is my
Wellness Plan so that I could be and
feel well
and in the absence of a plan there's
going to be stress and when there's a
lot of stress then there's no time to
rejuvenate and what I find for myself is
when I allow myself to get too stressed
then the easy things are hard and the
hard things feel nearly impossible
and so this is my plea to you to come up
with some time where you can take half a
day off just to focus on you get off of
Technology get off of TV get off of
radio get off of social media and focus
on your health and well-being rule
number eight unleash your full potential
and whenever I ski I get these
bursts of inspiration
and that's part of actually not being
focused on work
actually allows your imagination and
creativity to
I guess filter through and I had this
thought
that I want to share with you
around one of the greatest lessons I
learned and I've shared this before with
many of my students and my exceptional
life coaching program
and that is this you can set your goals
to based on your current level of skills
your current level of knowledge
your you know circumstances conditions
or
you can set your goals based on what you
want to achieve and then figure out what
skills do you need what knowledge do you
need what help do you need what beliefs
do you need
in order to achieve those goals in
essence
setting your goals based on current
circumstances
is a limited way of doing it in my
opinion when I know that you and I have
you know a hundred billion dollar brain
that can go to work to figure out how to
achieve almost anything
and so as we you know get into a new
year I want you to ask yourself some
questions
are you training your life for what you
love are you living the lifestyle of
your dreams or is there a dream life you
would really love to live
how healthy would you love to be how
much income would you love to make how
much charity would you love to give how
would your relationships be if they were
just the way you wanted them
and why not start with what you really
really really want and don't allow
yourself
to you know look at your present
circumstances or what's happening in the
world right now but instead go and
create the circumstances internally and
externally to achieve your goals and
dreams give that a shot what I can
promise you is by focusing on what you
want
and being creative and using your
spiritual genius using your emotional
management techniques that you can
upgrade using your ability to stay
focused and more aware to get this
physical body of yours into action
you'll be able to achieve more of your
goals and dreams and if you set your
goals based on your current
circumstances or conditions
don't settle for less go for gold go for
being the best version of yourself and
become all that you're capable of
becoming rule number nine invest in your
present a few years ago I met a guy by
the name of Dr David Krueger and he's a
psychiatrist and he and I were talking
about stories that we have everybody has
a story we have a money story we teach
about winning the game we teach about
your money story and the winning game of
money program and how to reprogram your
brain for a stronger money story and we
have a story around our health our
relationships our career our businesses
we have a story about everything and
then we go about living that story over
and over and over again and very few
people think about the fact that we are
repeating the same patterns in many
cases of our parents or even of our own
lives from the time we are 20 30 40 50
60. well what if you can go to the
Future
and you can think about if I could
change my story today that would get me
to the Future that I want what would the
story say
and in the book
I've given you some inner sizes and some
exercises to start writing out your
story now you may think what do you mean
write out my story
I learned many years ago to write out my
money story my life story my
relationship story and I've always
started in this fashion I'm so happy and
grateful for the fact that I am living
the life of my dreams and I am traveling
all over the world first class and I am
able to give to the Charities that my
wife and I and children love and I'm
able to and I write down in present
tense everything that I'm doing feeling
experiencing for health wealth
relationships career business finances
fun experiences charity I write down a
page or two pages that is a story that I
want my future to be like
and then
I type it out
lazy right by hand I type it out and
then I laminate it then I'll record it
and then I'll listen to it over and over
and over again now you may think that
sounds silly why would you do that why
because any information that you get in
through the senses through your ears
through your eyes that you touch that
you feel activates neurons in the brain
when those neurons are activated and
they wire together if you repeat it
often enough your brain says hey you're
investing a lot of time and energy on
this stuff let me start to put some
automatic processes to make that story
real
and this is where winning
From the Inside Out comes to play this
is why using meditation and
visualization and mindfulness and
affirmations and emotional emotional
management techniques and subliminal
programming all work if you can get the
information into the brain and you have
spaced repetition backed with emotion
you are going to develop the neural
patterns that will activate something
called automaticity all right or
automaticity is when these neurons
activate automatically and then your
perspective changes your beliefs start
to change your behavior starts to change
the filters by which you see the world
and the lens by which you see the world
start to match up with the story one of
the first things we do in our when the
game of money program is we help people
program a new money story so they can
then earn the money they want and live
the life of their dreams and Rule Number
10 the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is believe I remember
25 years ago when my first son was born
in May of 1995. I felt this incredible
gift that was being given to me and
something weird happened I went to the
bathroom when my wife's water broke and
I showered and I scrubbed myself you
know from head to toe with a brush
and the thinking that was going on in my
head at the time was for the last let's
say nine months or so this unborn child
was in my wife's belly and whatever was
happening this intelligence and and you
know nature doing its thing I was about
to get this gift and I remember thinking
and I'm not religious just so you know
thinking that God was giving me this
gift right and this miracle this just
incredible
thing called a baby and I remember
feeling extremely emotional
my life was about to change
and it certainly did I have been
so so so grateful and blessed and
involved every day in the life of my son
Keenan who was born 25 years ago and my
son Noah who was born 23 years ago
and the purpose of this specific video I
wanna just
Focus for just a moment on life
have you really ever given some thought
to What it Took what it takes to to give
and sustain life so if we reverse back
you know your life
for however many years you've been born
to the day you were born and reversed
back around 285 days from when your
mother and father had sex and the sperm
in the egg connected and the X
chromosomes and the Y chromosomes
interlocked and multiplied 26 times
until you were born
have you ever considered
the billions of years of evolution to
make that happen the Perfection of that
happening many years ago when I wrote
one of my books I likened life happening
to a printing press imagine if you are
standing outside of a printing press you
know a company or a building that that
produces books or newspapers and imagine
that in this printing press
or this printing business there's ink
there's paper there's letters you know
the little letters that you stamp onto
things there's everything that's needed
to make a newspaper or to you know to
print a book and imagine that this
printing business explodes and all of a
sudden somehow by Miracle it all comes
together and then a book lands you know
on the table right next to you or on the
floor right next to you
the idea of that happening is crazy
right
well the miracle that you are is crazy
right it's just oh my God what an
incredible Miracle you are
that I am that we are
and so today I wanted to just remind you
of the intelligence that created you the
intelligence that is within you that you
are so feeling less than feeling like
you're not good enough feeling like
you're not smart enough feeling like
you're not worthy enough
really
you are a miracle of life you are a
miracle of creation
within you the hydrogen the oxygen the
nitrogen the carbon and all the other
elements the atoms and the molecules
that make you you
is Nature's perfection
yes with all of our flaws at
idiosyncrasies and challenges and and
things we do great and things we don't
that's the miracle of you you are unique
only one of a kind
you're not supposed to be like anybody
else you're not supposed to feel better
than or worse than less than anybody
else equal
every day every minute every hour every
month every year you are a miracle
why not
act that way why not feel the miracle
that you are why not be express love
give share understand be compassionate
be empathetic to another human being who
is a miracle
and take a look all around you
because life is a miracle
Albert Einstein said you can either live
your life as if everything is a miracle
or nothing is a miracle well today
I want to let you know you are a miracle
at the end of your day or week do you
ever find yourself worried or frustrated
because no matter how much effort you
put in to work and no matter how hard
you work your financial situation and
your financial future may never seem to
be improving you might be finding
yourself living paycheck to paycheck
right now with not a lot of breathing
room and I would imagine no
discretionary income or even time to
spend on the little things that really
would make your life more enjoyable well
what I can share with you is you're not
alone that's number one and in most
cases the real problem is not your
current circumstances what the real
problem is that most people repeat the
same patterns of thought and behaviors
over and over again and that is the
cause of what more of the same results
but they are looking for different
results and so today I'm going to show
you how to break that pattern break that
cycle now you see when you think of your
results your results are effects and so
the question is effects of what and the
answer is your results are all effects
of what you believe to be true about
yourself what you believe to be true
that is possible and it also comes down
to what are your daily habits now if you
think about what you believe and if you
think about your habits that is what is
causing the effect that you may not like
right now and so a simple logical thing
to to do would be to understand that if
I could change my beliefs about what was
possible and what was possible for me
specifically and I could create more
empowering habits than my result will
change and what I love to focus on
having done an enormous amount of brain
research over the last 10 years is
something called your inner game and
your inner game is comprised of
obviously your beliefs your attitude
your perceptions how you see the world
and your inner game is also comprised of
what causes you to take action and so
let me share just a little story with
you that may help you understand what I
mean
about two years ago I was at a seminar
and when I got off the stage this woman
started walking towards me and I could
see she was somewhere in her you know
50s maybe early 60s she looked nice she
was a vibrant woman she was walking
right towards me and I saw tears
streaming down her eyes and when she got
through the crowd for a moment I thought
that maybe there was something wrong but
she actually had tears of joy in her
eyes and when I met her her name was
Joni Sanderson and this was in Perth
Australia and she came up to me she said
thank you so much and I go well for what
she says well
about a year ago I heard you speak about
beliefs and habits and mastering my
emotions and really working on my
self-worth and she said to me that she
was a caregiver and that she loved
helping families who needed extra
assistance for their aging parents or
for their children who may need some
additional help in the home so she was a
wonderful caregiver but she was living
on a Widow's pension of about twelve
thousand Aussie dollars a year and so
she really didn't have enough money to
be able to take the care of her
grandkids that she wanted to to be able
to take her children on a vacation and
so I shared with her why do you think
that you're only earning twelve thousand
dollars a year and she said I don't know
and when I shared with her that she
possibly believed that that's what she
was worth and she said to me I think I'm
worth more I said well you might be able
to declare that you're worth more but if
at a deeper level of your brain you have
this feeling that maybe you're not smart
enough or not good enough or not worthy
enough
that is what is going to drive your
behavior and so what I helped Joni do
prior to her coming to me and being in
gratitude was I helped her recognize
that beliefs Drive Behavior beliefs
Drive emotions habits Drive behavior and
in order to change your results living
paycheck to paycheck being stressed out
worrying about your future even your
presence circumstances right now why not
focus on working on the neural patterns
the beliefs and habits that are nothing
more than patterns in the brain that
drive 96 to 98 of your behavior and so
she started to work on what I call a
belief and habit modification program
and while she did this she started to
see herself in a different light she
started to feel more confident more
certain and More in empowered and what I
can share with you is she at that moment
told me that she went from making twelve
thousand dollars a year as a widows from
a Widow's pension and living paycheck to
paycheck
to being able to charge for her services
and she was making 75
000 a year when you start talking about
my brain it's an organ it's like your
heart is an organ you can speed up your
heart you can slow down your heart you
can you know speed up the brain waves in
your brain you can slow them down you
can tune in you can tune out we haven't
been given the user's manual for the
most powerful we're aware of that's
right and so the great news you know I
know you being an athlete in a
successful businessman you have
discipline you cannot you can't achieve
yourself achieve results without some
kind of discipline and so we know that
there's some fundamental truths to
achieving success and every successful
person will tell you you know and Jim
Rohn is I know you you love Jim Royce so
you either pay the price of discipline
or you pay the price of regret
discipline weighs ounces regret weighs
tons but the thing is can you teach
discipline the answer is yes how you
have to have a willing part participant
and if the participants reason why
is big enough if they know I want to
achieve X and the reason why the motive
for their action motivation the motive
for their action is a reason Beyond just
themselves chances are they will do more
to achieve that success than if it was
just left up to their own but there are
some people that are born you know with
Incredible Drive they just have this
insatiable drive and they'll just I'll
do whatever it takes
for the things that I want and there's
other people that want things but they
just don't have this insatiable Drive
and this is where you know I as much as
I hated school I love to use schools and
analogy yeah in The Game of Life whether
it's health wealth relationships career
business spirituality fun experiences
you have to decide what level the game
do I want to play at is it the great
school level the kindergarten level the
high school level the university level
the pro level because each one of those
levels requires a totally different
mindset and totally different skill set
they're building blocks on each other
but if you are extremely talented but
you're not prepared to practice and
rehearse and drill and fall and fail
forward to the next attempt you will
never make it as a pro you will never
make as a pro business person you'll
never make it as a pro husband or wife
or athlete or musician you just never
will so just get used to that if you're
not prepared to pay the price
if you are prepared to pay the price and
you have the aptitude the talent now
we're talking about there's some real
potential here and what we don't know is
you know what's in your heart like what
is the fire that stirs you that that you
wake up saying I will do this even when
I don't feel like it I will do whatever
it takes to overcome my Temptation for
mediocracy my Temptation for excuses my
Temptation for
um reasons and circumstances to hold me
back I won't allow those to be in my way
um and if you have that within you
you'll achieve whatever you choose right
and so the question you asked before is
how do you develop that start small yeah
start small
so if you don't have discipline show to
your show yourself that you can give
yourself one command and one follow
through so you know what
um right now I'm going to get up I'm
going to do two push-ups right now not
not like later now can you give yourself
a simple command one sit up right now
I'm gonna go get a glass of water you
start with something ridiculous I
learned many years ago reduce it to the
ridiculous so for reducing to the
Ridiculousness I start I said can you do
that great will you
because that's the difference right
there is that's the razor's Edge the
people who can will you will you yeah
great when now now yeah right so if you
develop that skill and specifically from
a brain plasticity a neuroplasticity
perspective as soon as you do that you
give yourself a command
and you take the action you have just
created a neural pattern that you can
give yourself a command and take action
now that maybe just be one time well
what if you did that every hour by
putting a little bell on your computer
and every hour like if you're if my
computer was open I'd have um every hour
it would say it's 12 o'clock it's one
o'clock and I take 60 Seconds
just to be in control of my mind 66 I
don't care where I'm not what you're
doing stop takes six breaths just get it
just gets centered am I on track am I
off track am I doing something I
shouldn't be doing versus a high impact
activity that I need to be doing every
hour I've trained myself to just reset
I didn't always do that so I just
started with
One A Day right then two sure then three
then it was working so well I said great
let's do this every hour what if you
said Okay I want to make let's just say
a hundred thousand dollars a year or a
million it doesn't make a difference and
I asked you
what do you need to believe about
yourself
to achieve this so I need to believe I'm
smart enough good write down I am smart
enough what else do you need to believe
I need to believe that I am worthy I
need to believe that I deserve this I
need to believe that it's possible I
need to believe you write down five or
six or seven beliefs or just words on a
sheet of paper
now let me stop for just a moment I'm
going to tell a story and come back to
this I want you to imagine that somebody
tapped you on the shoulder sometime
today and say hey
um I work with Steven Spielberg and Tom
Hanks in Hollywood and we have this new
script okay that if you get really good
at this script where you could read it
in front of a camera without the script
we'll pay you 10 million bucks now I
want you to imagine you've never seen
the script you don't know how to act but
they said to you we're going to give you
an acting coach we're going to give you
everything you need to memorize the
script we're going to do everything you
need to act it perfectly what would you
do to take that script that's on a piece
of paper that you've never seen before
what would you do to take that script
to make it yours for you to own it and
the answer is you probably read it like
what once uh would you read it maybe a
hundred times 200 times 500 times you
think you might role play with somebody
while you're holding the script in your
hand do you think you might research the
rule do you think you might take a
camera and practice it and do you think
that if you practice it one time 50
times 100 times 500 times you can
finally put the script down and you get
in front of the camera and go boom here
is the script do you think you could do
that well guess what a script that's on
a piece of paper that you don't believe
with practice you start to believe so
what happens if you take a belief
system and you start to imprint it into
your subconscious mind initially through
conscious repetition but there are ways
to access the subconscious mind that we
know today that are faster and easier
than just doing it consciously and so
you take a vision of you achieving your
goals and dreams you take the beliefs
you need you learn how to manage your
emotions a little bit better and then
you develop the habits which again are
nothing more than neural patterns in the
brain they've been reinforced and when
you learn how to deactivate the
destructive ones and activate
constructive ones through space
repetition and reinforcement now you are
resetting your default way of being so a
belief is nothing more than a reinforced
pattern that if you learn how to
deactivate it and create a new one it's
like a software upgrade for your brain
someone's listening right now and
they're thinking you know there's a lot
of things I want you know I want to get
out of this relationship or I want the
relationship I want to have a better
health I want to have more money which I
may be and they've been saying that for
years and they feel like they've been
consuming all the information they need
to have but they haven't been able to
take action maybe because their why
isn't powerful enough what would you say
should be their first step well the
first step is to take one thing I'm
going to go back to one thing yeah and
say great let me move one thing forward
why because that just changes the
trajectory of the same pattern repeating
itself and as soon as you interrupt a
pattern and then you repeatedly
interrupt the pattern it's like taking a
detour
and as soon as you take a detour one day
you're like okay that was that was okay
but you intended your tendency is to
want to go back to what's comfortable
but if you take the detour two days Six
Days Seven Days we know from a
neuroscience perspective it takes about
66 days to create a solid enough neural
pattern that it'll go from conscious
effort and thinking about it to a
non-conscious pattern that has the
beginnings of automaticity happening
without your involvement you're just
doing them yeah and so for me what I do
and for myself
is I uh whenever I want to change
something whether it's a habit whether
it's a thought or emotion or behavior I
say I'm going to work on this for 100
days not 30 days not 21 days not 66
which is right around there I say 100
days
and then I focus all of my just on that
one thing for 100 days why you give an
example of something you've done Sugar
Sugar I'm a sugar me too I'm a sugar
like if he was an alcoholic I'm a sugar
it's so bad so you take one thing just
one thing that you know maybe a little
challenging 100 days 100 days just 100
days so let's say you want to drink more
water 100 days a glass a day
conscious effort to want to do whatever
you did before you'll still do but one
glass a day so you know I started that
with my assistance I want to drink you
know like four of these a day you know
like you know 32 ounces whatever the
case is and so every we got a mug and
it's on my desk every time I walk in and
then I have some support from her saying
hey remember to drink your water so just
do it so the first you know two three
weeks I feel like I'm gonna drown myself
with so much water
um but then it's like okay now I'm used
to it now I'm drinking as much water as
possible because the Habit is there and
one of the rules that I love to follow
is the Habit is more important than the
intensity at first
so don't worry about the intensity right
develop the habit
so can you take one minute a day to
focus on how you will achieve a goal
just one minute a day
can you take one minute a day to focus
on your health
you take one day to retrain your brain
yeah can I take one day
you know or one action a day right and
you start off with something you know
and reduce it down to just a minute or
two minutes or one Behavior if you can
get that behavior to be a habit it's
easy to stack right of course it's just
like the foundation of a building once
you have the foundation if you build it
right you stack and so every good
discipline affects another and every bad
discipline affects others when I analyze
businesses
whether they're startups or doing a
hundred million dollars in Revenue
doesn't make a difference
usually there's something in one of
those three or all of those three that
is missing and so when we start to focus
on getting the inner game right plus
what you need to do and then you do it
the results are pretty easy so here's
what I want you to ask yourself
are there people out there
all right that could buy your product or
service but you don't know how to reach
them
right is it possible that there's people
out there that need what you have your
product your service your knowledge your
skills whatever it is that you're
selling offering to the marketplace is
it possible that you just don't know how
to reach them so that means that it's a
skill set issue right now in 2021
we know how to do those things there
like I said earlier where I started
right the fact that there are two
billion people a day online
means that there's more than enough
people to get in front of listen in the
old in the old days right
um when we didn't have the internet we
had to advertise you know the newspapers
postcards magazines radio television or
set up a store in a shopping center
but now just about every single business
okay is online offering information
content to develop a relationship and
rapport with prospects and they're
taking them through a process Yellow
Pages that's right thank you Muse Debbie
Debbie Muse right so yellow pages so
here's the thing one of the formulas
that you must figure out is where I
started before
traffic times conversion equals Revenue
the added version to that is traffic
times conversion plus repeat business
and referrals equals exponential Revenue
traffic times conversion equals Revenue
Now traffic times conversion plus
referrals and repeat business equals
exponential revenue and so one of the
things that you need to be thinking
about okay and if this is the only thing
that you leave today I'm going to give
you a couple things number one is I need
to adapt I need to adapt to the market
and use all the tools available to me
but not use every one of them I want you
to ask yourself the question I posed
earlier is what has to happen in order
for me to just double or triple the
leads that I get
leads the the prospects coming to see
you online or offline if you just
focused on that question
what has to happen in order for me to
double or triple my prospects or leads
and I'm not sure who said that you
picked up the answer Virginia yeah this
is
this is my New York Times best-selling
book The Answer uh if anybody's read it
uh it is a New York Times bestseller for
many many many years now one of the best
books on the inner game and outer game
of business
uh I put that back over there on my on
my thing
um but I didn't come here to to sell you
on my on my book I want to give you
information if anybody wants to get the
book on Amazon uh for 15 or less
um it'll blow your mind and the Lux
Coast you're reading it now awesome so
when we understand there's already a
process in place
and we discover how do we take our
product or service and create the
marketing how many of you are you good
in marketing
are you good in marketing meaning I'm
not talking about branding I'm talking
about getting your product or service
with the right message in front of the
ideal client
if you're not good at marketing okay I
want you to let me know are you good at
marketing yes or no so you're not good
at marketing
think about this if you're a business
owner there's a couple of different hats
that you have to make sure are being
taken care of right in business if
you're a business owner with a product
or service you have to have somebody
who's doing the marketing right which is
developing your brand creating your
messaging for how you're going to
promote your product or service to
people who don't know you you have to
learn how to sell and selling is doing
something for somebody not to somebody
you need to learn how to manage you need
to learn how to either develop products
you need to learn some of the technology
needs that you have there's a lot of
different hats that you have to wear
or you have to make sure that somebody
in your company is wearing that hat
right and so imagine if you're um needs
surgery but you're not a good surgeon
what would you do you'd have to find how
do I get somebody who could do the
surgery so for those of you who are not
good at marketing or sales which is the
oxygen required for any business
regardless of how good your product or
service are the question you want to be
asking yourself is this who can I hire
to help me or who can I barter with to
help me who can I partner with to help
me do my marketing and sales if you're
not good at that so higher partner
barter or defer payment to get it done
because without
marketing and selling
you really don't have a business and
those are skills that either you have
that you need to develop or you don't
have you're not good at you don't want
it but you still need to figure out as a
business owner how am I going to get it
done your job as a business owner is not
to do everything but to make sure that
everything that is oxygen and is
required gets done until you learn how
to master your mindset by recognizing
what's holding you back the real reasons
that you're not taking the actions that
you need to take and learn how to
reframe them in the right part of your
brain so you can override the messaging
signal from the amygdala the fear Center
the emotional center of the brain to the
part of the brain that's responsible for
taking action
you're never going to achieve your goals
so whether you have doubts or fears or
anxieties for your success fear failure
fear losing your job fear losing your
home fear losing your money
you have to understand that just like a
car has a light that pops up on the
dashboard when something's wrong in the
engine
you have an emotion that is your signal
to let you know whether you're feeling
good or not whether you're comfortable
or not whether you have certainty or not
whether you have confidence or not and
if you're lacking the confidence and the
certainty it's going to cause doubt if
you're going to have doubt it may cause
anxiety and as soon as that sets in the
brain in a nanosecond your ability to
take action is like having one foot on
the gas and one foot on the brake
there's gonna be a lot of movement going
on the tires but you're really not going
to get anywhere so the first thing I
want you to do is write down what's
really holding you back why aren't you
really get clear get deep why aren't you
really taking action towards any of your
goals health goals financial goals
business goals whatever goals you have
write that down and ask yourself
is this real is this imagined is it a
probability or is it a possibility what
you'll find for the most part is the
negative consequence
is a possibility and as soon as you buy
into that possibility you're going to do
everything possible to run away to fight
Freeze or fight that feeling
but when you learn how to switch your
brain from recognizing what's holding
you back
to reframing the possibility to to for
the probability to just a normal
possibility
you start to activate different parts of
your brain that start showing you the
solutions to how to overcome the fear
how to overcome the risk how to overcome
the possible negative consequence and
then what happens is the amygdala the
part of your brain that's responsible to
protect you and keep you safe the firing
threshold of that signal gets lowered
the message to the motor cortex doesn't
get sent so you start take action and
third what is happening is that your
left prefrontal cortex the CEO the
genius part of your brain starts to
think about ways that you can actually
take action and do it faster and easier
and better it starts to change what you
see start to change your vibration and
now you start to have a lot more control
over not just having goals and having
strategies and plans but getting
yourself to take action if we have
constructive positive empowering beliefs
we move forward and take action but when
we have a limiting belief like I'm not
good enough I'm not smart enough I'm not
worthy I'm not skilled I'm too young I'm
too old I'm too white I'm too black them
to Asian Caucasian I'm this or I'm that
I'm not enough of this I'm not enough of
that
where are our beliefs
right we have two types of beliefs we
have conscious beliefs that we can
declare and that we have subconscious
beliefs as well which ones are the more
powerful of the two Mike Edwards says
subconscious beliefs
right Mike
says subconscious beliefs were you born
with any beliefs like if you were a
neuroanatomist
okay if you're a neuroanatomist if you
were to look in the brain where would
you find your beliefs the positive the
negative ones the good ones the
challenging ones the constructive
destroy where would you find them what
are they like what are they
right like what are they
aren't those patterns that have been
reinforced based on what we learned in
childhood aren't those patterns that our
parents gave us our teachers our
brothers our sisters our neighbors
right didn't we
develop our beliefs
through the imprinting year zero to five
or six the modeling years five or six to
you know seven or eight and then the um
the um
um experiential years right all the way
from birth to 25 26 when our brain was
pretty plastic and we developed these
beliefs about what to believe we weren't
born with any they're nothing more than
neural patterns in the brain now how
many of you have heard the word
neuroplasticity
neuroplasticity right what is
neuroplasticity neuroplasticity is the
scientific fact that our brain is
plastic
right what does that mean it's not like
plastic like this brain it means that we
have brain cells right so the brain
cells okay there's a cell there's an
axon okay or a body then there's
dendrites at the end right and there's
synapse gaps in between the brain cells
so those brains have potentiality and
let's say we are told that you're not
good enough you're not smart enough
you're not worthy you'll never amount to
much you're too young you're too old you
don't have enough knowledge you don't
have enough skill if those patterns are
created in those neurons are active and
releasing those neural chemicals from a
receptor or from a um ascending neuron
to a receptor neuron and that happens
often enough that neuron structure or
pathway
becomes more solid just like
developing a highway system in a city
and the pathways that are active in
reinforcement We Are Young become the
default Pathways just like the highways
and the roads that you take every single
day to go to the stores you take now if
it's true that our neural pathways are
not fixed but the pathways that are easy
to run across okay or to fire the
signals okay are the ones that are
dominant is it possible to let go of the
limiting destructive disempowering
beliefs
that somebody else gave us for the most
part or we experienced
is it possible that through
conditioning programming deliberately
choosing our beliefs
and reinforcing new neural Pathways we
can
create new neural pathways
right so if a neural pathway can be
created and neural Pathways can be
deactivated
then why not deliberately and
consciously evolve yourself
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see my last one-on-one with the
amazing John ass rap check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there well we all own the most
powerful bio computer in the world in
the universe and most people don't know
how to change their brain to change
their income